A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
一阵清新的水花将触及你心灵的深处。那些汹涌的蓝色海浪可以推动你前行，也可以抚平你的心情。从密歇根的海岸到海岸。只需在当下感受这份流动。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流和溪流创造出永恒的记忆。赶快加入进来，在“纯粹密歇根”感受清新的洗礼吧。请登录 Michigan.org 保持新鲜感。或访问我们的网站。
Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child that won't be suitable for all listeners. Today, the district of Notting Hill in London's inner west is renowned as one of the city's more affluent areas. But in the late 1940s, it was not a desirable place to live. A number of its buildings had been damaged or completely ravaged during the Blitz, an intensive German bombing campaign during the Second World War that killed more than 40,000 civilians. Many of the larger houses that remained standing were sold to landlords who divided them into multi-occupancy dwellings, with tenants leasing either a room or a single story. Ten Rillington Place in Notting Hill's Ladbrook Grove neighborhood was one such abode.
今天的剧集涉及一桩针对儿童的犯罪，可能并不适合所有听众。如今，伦敦内西区的诺丁山地区以该市较为富裕的社区之一而闻名。但在 20 世纪 40 年代后期，这里并不是一个理想的居住地。在第二次世界大战期间，这里的大量建筑在闪电战（德国针对英国的大规模轰炸行动，导致4万多名平民丧生）中遭到破坏或彻底摧毁。许多幸存的大房子被卖给房东，房东将它们分隔成多人合住的住宅，租客们租下一间房或一层楼。诺丁山拉德布鲁克格罗夫社区的灵顿街 10 号就是这样一处住所。
It was the 10th house in a row of narrow, matching three-story brick residences situated at the end of a cul-de-sac that adjoined a busy thoroughfare named St. Mark's Road. All of the houses had been built during the 1870s and by the late 1940s they had fallen into neglect and disrepair. As they were home to so many residents, the street had a bustling atmosphere, with local children often gathering outside to play during the summer months. The landlord for number 10 lived elsewhere. They had split the house into three flats that each occupied an entire story of the building. It was poorly maintained and had no phone or indoor bathroom facilities.
它是尽头死胡同里一排狭窄、相连的三层砖砌住宅中的第 10 座房子，死胡同毗邻一条名为圣马克路的繁忙大道。所有房屋均建于 19 世纪 70 年代，到 20 世纪 40 年代末，它们已经年久失修。由于这里住着如此多的居民，这条街呈现出熙熙攘攘的景象，当地的孩子们经常在夏日聚在外面玩耍。10号的房东住在别处。他们将房子分成了三套公寓，每套公寓占据建筑的一整层。它维护不善，没有电话或室内浴室设施。
Instead, residents had to use bedpans or a lavatory in the backyard, which adjoined a small communal wash house. In March 1948, the property's ground and middle-floor flats were leased to long-term tenants, but the top floor remained available to rent. Newlyweds, Timothy and Beryl Evans had been living with Timothy's parents and sisters just around the corner on St. Mark's Road. Their living quarters were small and crowded. When Beryl discovered she was pregnant, she and Timothy decided it was time to find a place of their own. They were informed of a house nearby that had a sign in its top-floor window reading, Flat to Let. Its affordability, coupled with its convenient location near their extended family,
相反，居民们不得不使用便盆或后院的厕所，后院毗邻一个小型的公共洗衣房。1948 年 3 月，该房产的底层和中间层公寓被长期租户租下，但顶层仍然空置招租。新婚夫妇蒂莫西和贝瑞尔·埃文斯此前一直和蒂莫西的父母及姐妹们住在圣马克路转角处。他们的起居空间既小又拥挤。当贝瑞尔发现自己怀孕时，她和蒂莫西决定是时候找一个属于他们自己的地方了。他们得知附近有一所房子，其顶层窗户上挂着一块写着“出租公寓”的牌子。它负担得起的租金，加上靠近他们大家庭的便利位置，
compelled the Evans' to submit an application, despite the property's less than desirable features. Their submission was approved, and on Monday, March 29, 1948, the young couple moved into 10 Rillington Place. Beryl, Susanna Thorley Beryl Susanna Thorley was born on September 19, 1929, in the south-east London area of Lewisham. She was the oldest of four children, with two younger brothers and a sister. During the Second World War, the Thorleys moved to the west London neighbourhood of Kensington. When Beryl's mother died in 1947, her father relocated to the Seaside Resort of Brighton, roughly 53 miles south of the capital. Beryl remained in London, where she worked as a telephone switchboard operator at Groverner House Hotel on Park Lane, a hotel in the upmarket district of Mayfair.
促使埃文斯夫妇提出了申请，尽管这处房产的条件并非那么理想。他们的申请得到了批准，1948 年 3 月 29 日星期一，这对年轻夫妇搬进了灵顿街 10 号。贝瑞尔·苏珊娜·索利贝瑞尔·苏珊娜·索利于 1929 年 9 月 19 日出生于伦敦东南部刘易舍姆地区。她是四个孩子中的老大，有两个弟弟和一个妹妹。二战期间，索利一家搬到了伦敦西区的肯辛顿。1947年贝瑞尔的母亲去世后，她的父亲搬到了海滨度假胜地布赖顿，该地位于首都以南约 53 英里处。贝瑞尔留在伦敦，在位于梅费尔高档区帕克巷的格罗夫纳豪务酒店担任电话总机接线员。
One of her colleagues was dating a young man, who in turn offered to set Beryl up on a blind date with his friend. Timothy John Evans was born on November 20, 1924, in the Welsh mining town of Murther Tidville, located in the country's south. His father, who worked locally as a coal haulier, abandoned the family seven months before Timothy was born. As a result, Timothy and his older sister Eileen were raised by their mother, Thomasina. In 1929, she remarried another coal worker named Penry Probert. Later that year, the newlyweds had a daughter, Mary. Timothy Evans' childhood was marred by a number of developmental delays. He struggled to walk and speak, though eventually learned how to do both. At age eight, Timothy cut a toe on his right foot on some glass by a river. The wound was bandaged to using a dirty cloth, which led to him developing tubercular veruca, a rash of small, red, papula nodules related to the infectious disease tuberculosis.
她的同事之一当时在和一个年轻男子交往，这名男子转而主动提出让贝瑞尔和他的朋友进行一次相亲。蒂莫西·约翰·埃文斯于 1924 年 11 月 20 日出生于威尔士南部采矿小镇默瑟蒂德维尔。他的父亲是一名当地的煤炭搬运工，在蒂莫西出生前七个月抛弃了家庭。因此，蒂莫西和他的姐姐艾琳是由母亲托马西娜抚养长大的。1929 年，她改嫁给另一位名叫彭里·普罗伯特的煤炭工人。同年晚些时候，这对新婚夫妇生下了一个女儿玛丽。蒂莫西·埃文斯的童年伴随着许多发育迟缓的问题。他在走路和说话方面都很吃力，不过最终学会了这两项技能。八岁时，蒂莫西在河边被玻璃划破了右脚脚趾。伤口用一块脏布包扎，导致他患上了结核性疣，这是一种与结核病相关的、由小型红色丘疹组成的皮疹。
The injury never healed properly, and Timothy was often in hospital receiving treatments. He missed out on much of his schooling, causing his literacy to suffer to the extent that he could barely write and could only read simple texts such as comic books. In 1935, when Timothy was ten years old, the Welsh coalfields were experiencing a depression, so his stepfather relocated to London in search of work. The rest of the family joined him six weeks later, settling in the cities in the West. Timothy continued to miss school due to his ill health. In 1939, he was sent to a clinic in Hampshire that specialized in treating children with tuberculosis and stayed for an entire year. Though the physicians there couldn't entirely fix Timothy's foot injury, they managed to treat it effectively enough that it never bothered him significantly again, though he was left with a permanent limp. By the time he reached adulthood, Timothy stood at five foot five inches tall and had a slight frame. Described as cocky and cheerful, he had dark eyes and dark hair, which he slicked back across his head.
这个伤口一直没有完全愈合，蒂莫西经常在医院接受治疗。他错过了大部分学业，导致他的识字能力受到很大影响，以至于他几乎不会写字，只能阅读漫画书等简单的文本。1935 年，蒂莫西十岁时，威尔士煤田正经历经济萧条，因此他的继父搬到伦敦寻找工作。其余家人六周后也加入了他的行列，定居在伦敦西部。由于身体健康状况不佳，蒂莫西继续逃学。1939 年，他被送到汉普郡的一家诊所，该诊所专门治疗患有结核病的儿童，并在那里待了整整一年。尽管那里的医生无法完全治愈蒂莫西的脚伤，但他们设法将其治疗得足够有效，此后再也没有对他的生活造成严重影响，尽管他留下了一个永久的跛足。到成年时，蒂莫西身高五英尺五英寸，身材瘦弱。他被形容为自负且开朗，拥有一双黑眼睛和向后梳理的黑发。
His leg impairment excused him from military service during World War II, and he remained in London with his family as the city endured the blitz. Although his limited education hindered his work prospects, he managed to secure a job as a car cleaner. Amongst friends and family, Timothy was renowned for exaggerating and telling tall tales. He'd developed the habit as a form of entertainment when he was bedridden as a child. He claimed that his father was an Italian count and that he had a brother who owned an enormous fleet of cars. Though he had a Welsh accent, he would sometimes feign a cockney manner of speaking to fit in with his English friends. Thomasina attributed her son's fibbing to his lack of self-confidence. If caught out in a lie, Timothy would become ashamed and would plead with his mother not to tell his older sister Eileen, whom he adored. In January 1947, shortly after Timothy's 22nd birthday, a friend offered to set him up on a date with a girl named Beryl Thorley.
他的腿部残疾使他在第二次世界大战期间免于服兵役，随着这座城市经受闪电战的摧残，他与家人留在了伦敦。尽管有限的教育阻碍了他的工作前景，但他还是设法找到了一份汽车清洗工的工作。在朋友和家人中，蒂莫西以夸大其词和讲离奇的故事而闻名。他在童年卧病在床时养成了这种习惯，以此作为一种娱乐方式。他声称他的父亲是一位意大利伯爵，并且他有一个拥有一支庞大车队的兄弟。虽然他带有威尔士口音，但他有时会假装伦敦腔的说话方式，以便融入他的英国朋友中。托马西娜将她儿子的编造归咎于他缺乏自信。如果谎言被戳穿，蒂莫西会感到羞耻，并会恳求母亲不要告诉他所崇拜的姐姐艾琳。1947 年 1 月，就在蒂莫西 22 岁生日后不久，一位朋友提出安排他和一位名叫贝瑞尔·索利的女孩约会。
Timothy was drawn to the petite, dark-haired Beryl, and the pair hit it off instantly. They met several more times to attend local dances and to go to the cinema. Within weeks of their first date, they became engaged. On September 20, one day after Beryl's 18th birthday, they married at Kensington Registry Office. Six months later, the couple moved into 10 Rillington Place in preparation of their growing family. Their flat consisted of a single bedroom with a joint living and kitchen space. Despite the cramped quarters and lack of modern amenities, they liked their new home and decided to stay put even when told of a ground floor flat available elsewhere that had its own garden and lavatory. Number 10 Rillington Place had several communal areas, including the hallway, staircase, and outside rear yard, so the evansers often saw their neighbours throughout the day.
蒂莫西被身材娇小、黑发碧眼的贝瑞尔所吸引，两人一拍即合。他们又多次见面，一起去参加当地的舞会和看电影。在第一次约会几周后，他们订婚了。9 月 20 日，即贝瑞尔 18 岁生日的第二天，他们在肯辛顿登记处结婚。六个月后，为了迎接他们不断壮大的家庭，这对夫妇搬进了灵顿街 10 号。他们的公寓由一间卧室以及一个起居室和厨房共用的空间组成。尽管空间局促且缺乏现代便利设施，但他们还是很喜欢这个新家，甚至在得知别处有一套带花园和厕所的底层公寓空出时，也决定留在这里不搬走。灵顿街 10 号有几个公共区域，包括走廊、楼梯和户外的后院，因此埃文斯夫妇在白天经常能见到他们的邻居。
The ground floor flat was home to another married couple, while the middle residence was occupied by an elderly man. Later that year, Timothy commenced a new job as a delivery driver for a food wholesaler. He managed to drive a van all over London, despite having difficulty reading signs and maps. On Sunday, October 10, 1948, Timothy and Beryl welcomed their firstborn, a girl they named Geraldine. Beryl was an affectionate mother, while Timothy spent hours playing with his daughter. He would bring her home small gifts that he collected throughout his delivery shifts. On Wednesday evenings, Thomasina would babysit her grandchild so that the new parents could go to the cinema together. Yet, their relationship grew increasingly fraught and difficult.
底层公寓住着另一对夫妇，而中间的住所则住着一位老。同年晚些时候，蒂莫西开始了一份新工作，担任一家食品批发商的送货司机。尽管阅读路标和地图有困难，他还是设法开着货车跑遍了整个伦敦。1948 年 10 月 10 日星期日，蒂莫西和贝瑞尔迎来了他们的第一个孩子，一个他们取名为杰拉丁的女孩。贝瑞尔是一位慈爱的母亲，而蒂莫西则花数小时和女儿玩耍。他会把他在送货途中收集的小礼物带回家。每周三晚上，托马西娜都会帮他们照看孙女，这样这对新手父母就可以一起去看电影了。然而，他们的关系变得越来越紧张和困难。
Money was scarce. They struggled to afford rent and make repayments on their furniture. Timothy felt his wife did not know how to cook, clean, or manage a household budget. Beryl was frustrated at the amount of time and money her husband spent drinking at local pubs. He also had a quick temper that was exacerbated by alcohol. Their neighbours overheard their loud arguments, which sometimes became physical. By July 1949, Beryl had returned to work part-time to support her family. She struck up a mild flirtation with a colleague and once teased Timothy about it when he paid her a visit. He slapped her, and the pair caused a scene that resulted in Beryl losing her job.
金钱匮乏。他们很难支付房租和偿还家具分期付款。蒂莫西觉得他的妻子不知道如何做饭、打扫卫生或管理家庭预算。贝瑞尔则对她丈夫花在当地酒馆喝酒的时间和金钱感到沮丧。他脾气暴躁，酒精更是加剧了这一缺点。他们的邻居无意中听到了他们大声的争吵，有时甚至演变成肢体冲突。到 1949 年 7 月，贝瑞尔为了补贴家用，已经重返兼职工作。她与一位同事产生了轻微的暧昧关系，有一次在蒂莫西去看望她时还拿这件事逗他。他打了她一巴掌，两人闹出了乱子，导致贝瑞尔丢了工作。
On another occasion, Beryl threw a jar of baby cream at her husband, causing a gash that required stitches. Beryl's father concluded that his daughter was unhappily married, and her relationship with Timothy was not, quote, a genuine friendship. Other relatives and acquaintances were of the opposite opinion, believing the couple were happy and in love. Timothy's younger sister, Mary, attributed their marital issues to struggling to make ends meet in post-war London. A young girl who babysat Geraldine described them as a lovely couple, very fond of each other. They did quarrel a bit, but never badly, and never for long. On the evening of August 28, 1949, a police officer was called to 10 Rillington Place following reports of a loud fight.
在另一次事件中，贝瑞尔向丈夫扔了一罐婴儿面霜，导致他脸部被割伤，需要缝针。贝瑞尔的父亲得出结论，他的女儿婚姻不幸福，她与蒂莫西的关系“算不上真正的友谊”。其他亲戚和熟人则持相反观点，认为这对夫妇很幸福并且深爱着对方。蒂莫西的妹妹玛丽将他们的婚姻问题归咎于在战后伦敦难以维持生计。一个曾照看过杰拉丁的小女孩形容他们是一对恩爱夫妻，彼此非常喜爱。他们确实会争吵几句，但从不严重，也从不持久。1949 年 8 月 28 日晚上，一名警官接到关于激烈争吵的报警电话，被召至灵顿街 10 号。
In the top floor flat, they found Timothy, Beryl, Tomasina, and a teenage girl in the midst of an argument. The girl, 17-year-old Lucy Endicott, was a friend of Beryl's who was temporarily staying with the Evans''. Beryl had slapped Lucy after accusing her of sleeping with her husband the previous night. Tomasina was demanding Lucy leave as her presence was causing problems in her son's marriage. Lucy denied the allegations. She claimed to have witnessed Timothy beat Beryl and threatened to throw her out of a window. The feud ended with Lucy and Timothy leaving the flat. They stayed together for two nights until Lucy tired of his company and went home to her mother.
在顶层公寓里，他们发现蒂莫西、贝瑞尔、托马西娜和一个十几岁的女孩正处于激烈的争吵中。这个名叫露西·恩迪科特的 17 岁女孩是贝瑞尔的朋友，当时正暂住在埃文斯家。贝瑞尔扇了露西耳光，指控她在前一晚与自己的丈夫发生过性关系。托马西娜则要求露西离开，因为她的存在正在给她儿子的婚姻带来问题。露西否认了这些指控。她声称目睹了蒂莫西殴打贝瑞尔，并威胁要把她扔出窗外。这场争吵以露西和蒂莫西离开公寓而告终。他们在一起呆了两晚，直到露西厌倦了他的陪伴并回家找母亲。
Timothy returned to Beryl, who accepted him back. At around 7am on Tuesday, November 15, 1949, Cornelius Lynch was in the midst of preparing for work when he heard a knock on the front door. He was surprised to greet his 24-year-old nephew, Timothy Evans, the son of his sister, Tomasina. Timothy was far from home. Although he was born and raised in Southern Wales, he currently lived in London, 164 miles from Cornelius's house in the Welsh village of Murthervale. Timothy informed his uncle that he had been travelling with his boss searching for areas to expand his food wholesaler business. Their car broke down in the city of Cardiff, about half an hour's drive south, leaving them stranded for a few days at least. Cornelius and his wife, Violet, were happy to let their nephew stay with them for as long as he needed.
蒂莫西回到了贝瑞尔身边，而贝瑞尔接纳了他。1949 年 11 月 15 日星期二早晨 7 点左右，科尼利厄斯·林奇正准备去上班，突然听到敲门声。他惊喜地迎来了他 24 岁的侄子蒂莫西·埃文斯，也就是他姐姐托马西娜的儿子。蒂莫西离家很远。尽管他在南威尔士出生长大，但他目前住在伦敦，距离科尼利厄斯在威尔士村庄默瑟维尔的家有 164 英里。蒂莫西告诉他的叔叔，他一直在和他的老板一起旅行，寻找扩大其食品批发业务的地区。他们的汽车在卡迪夫市抛锚了，卡迪夫在南面约半小时车程的地方，这使他们至少滞留了几天。科尼利厄斯和他的妻子维奥莱特很高兴让他们的侄子在他们家住多久都行。
Timothy spent the following days going for walks in the nearby hills, reading comics by the fire and accompanying his aunt on shopping errands. A week-long absence from home would go unnoticed, as Beryl was holidaying at her widowed father's place in Brighton and had taken one-year-old Geraldine with her. A framed picture of the infant was displayed in the Lynch's house, and Timothy was often caught talking to it. On one occasion, he turned to his aunt, Violet, and told her, Just wait till you see her, Auntie Violet. She's a smasher. While at a pub with his nephew one day, Cornelius noticed Timothy holding what appeared to be a woman's wedding ring. When asked if it was Beryl's, Timothy said no, he'd just found it somewhere. He also gifted an old friend's wife a necklace, though didn't reveal where it had come from.
接下来的几天里，蒂莫西在附近的山丘上散步，在火炉旁读漫画书，并陪同他的阿姨采购杂货。由于贝瑞尔当时正在布赖顿她丧偶的父亲家度假，并且带上了一岁的杰拉丁，因此他离家一周并未引起注意。林奇家中摆放着一张婴儿的框装照片，蒂莫西经常被发现对着照片自言自语。有一次，他转向他的阿姨维奥莱特，对她说：“等您见到她就知道了，维奥莱特阿姨。她是个标致的孩子。”一天，在和侄子一起去酒馆时，科尼利厄斯注意到蒂莫西手里拿着一件看起来像是女性结婚戒指的东西。当被问及这是否是贝瑞尔的时，蒂莫西说不是，他只是在某个地方捡到的。他还送给了一位老朋友的妻子一条项链，但没有透露它是从哪里来的。
On his fifth day in Murthervale, Timothy celebrated his 25th birthday. He left the following day of Monday, November 21, telling the Lynch's he needed to meet his boss in Cardiff to collect some pay and expenses. Three days later, Timothy reappeared. He admitted to his aunt and uncle that he never went to Cardiff, he had actually been back to London. When asked if he had seen his wife and daughter during his brief trip home, Timothy replied that he had. He revealed that Beryl had walked out on him and baby Geraldine. During his journey back to Murthervale, he dropped his daughter off with some acquaintances in the city of Newport, just outside of Cardiff. The Lynch's were suspicious of their nephew's odd behavior and confusing explanations and were not inclined to believe that Beryl had abandoned him and her baby.
在默瑟维尔的第五天，蒂莫西庆祝了他的 25 岁生日。他在第二天（11 月 21 日星期一）离开，告诉林奇夫妇他需要去卡迪夫见他的老板以领取一些工资和报销费用。三天后，蒂莫西再次出现。他向他的叔叔和阿姨承认，他根本没有去卡迪夫，实际上是回过伦敦。当被问及他在短暂的回家之行中是否见过他的妻子和女儿时，蒂莫西回答说他见过了。他透露说，贝瑞尔抛弃了他和婴儿杰拉丁离家出走了。在返回默瑟维尔的途中，他把女儿留在了卡迪夫郊外纽波特市的一些熟人那里。林奇夫妇对侄子古怪的行为和混乱的解释产生怀疑，并不倾向于相信贝瑞尔抛弃了他和孩子。
One night, Cornelius asked Timothy to again confirm what had happened. He changed his story, this time saying Beryl was pregnant by another man so he had left her and would never see her again. Meanwhile, Timothy's mother and sisters hadn't heard from him in more than a fortnight. On Sunday, November 27, Timothy's sister Eileen visited 10 Rillington Place only to find the Evans' top story flat quiet. She inquired with the neighbors and spoke to the occupants of the ground floor flat, a middle-aged couple named John and Ethel Christie. Ethel reported that Beryl had left the property with Geraldine almost three weeks earlier on Tuesday, November 8. She was certain of it as she helped Beryl carry her bags. Ethel's husband to John told Eileen, they've had a row, best to leave young couples alone.
一天晚上，科尼利厄斯要求蒂莫西再次确认发生了什么事。他改变了说法，这一次他说贝瑞尔怀上了别人的孩子，所以他离开了他，并且再也不会见到她了。与此同时，蒂莫西的母亲和姐妹们已经有两周多没有听到他的消息了。11 月 27 日星期日，蒂莫西的妹妹艾琳拜访了灵顿街 10 号，却发现埃文斯家的顶层公寓静悄悄的。她向邻居打听，并与底层公寓的住户（一对名叫约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯特的中年夫妇）进行了交谈。埃瑟尔报告说，贝瑞尔在大约三周前的 11 月 8 日星期二带着杰拉丁离开了这里。她对此确信不疑，因为她曾帮贝瑞尔拎过行李。埃瑟尔的丈夫约翰对艾琳说：“他们吵了一架，最好别管年轻夫妇的事。”
The following day, Timothy's other sister Mary arrived at Rillington Place to carry out her own investigations. She also spoke with the Christie's and couldn't understand why Beryl hadn't written as she must have known they would worry if they didn't hear from her. John Christie revealed that Timothy had sold all the couple's furniture as though he had no intention to return. It appeared to have been in response to his mother, who was interfering with the couple's lives too much. John stated that Beryl left without saying goodbye, though his wife claimed otherwise, explaining Beryl bid her farewell and stated she would write. Mary planned to contact the police if she didn't hear from her brother or Beryl by the end of the week. John Christie advised her against it, as Timothy would not thank her if she involved the authorities in his personal matters. When Tomasina last spoke with her son, he claimed that Beryl and Geraldine were holidaying in Brighton.
第二天，蒂莫西的另一个妹妹玛丽来到灵顿街进行她自己的调查。她也与克里斯特夫妇交谈了，不明白为什么贝瑞尔没有写信，因为她一定知道如果听不到她的消息，他们会担心的。约翰·克里斯特透露，蒂莫西卖掉了这对夫妇所有的家具，仿佛他无意回来一样。这似乎是对他母亲干涉这对夫妇生活太多的回应。约翰声称贝瑞尔没有道别就离开了，尽管他的妻子声称并非如此，并解释说贝瑞尔向她告别并表示她会写信。玛丽计划如果到周末还没有听到她哥哥或贝瑞尔的消息就联系警方。约翰·克里斯特劝她不要这么做，因为如果她把当局卷入他的个人事务，蒂莫西是不会感谢她的。托马西娜最后一次与她儿子交谈时，他声称贝瑞尔和杰拉丁正在布赖顿度假。
Yet, it had been almost a month since the otherwise communicative Beryl contacted her in-laws. Tomasina sent a telegram to Beryl's father in Brighton, as she had purchased a dress for Geraldine as a Christmas gift and wanted to confirm Beryl would still be there before sending it. In his reply, Beryl's father revealed that his daughter hadn't been staying with him. A short time later, Tomasina received a letter from her sister-in-law, Violet Lynch, informing her that Timothy had spent the previous two weeks at her home in Murthervale. A number of individuals told Tomasina that her son owed them money, leading her to suspect he had run away from his debts. Furious that Timothy was lying and had seemingly abandoned his responsibilities, Tomasina wrote back to Violet. She panned. There is some mystery about him. You can tell him from me. I never want to see him again as long as I live. He packed up a good job here. He is like his father. No good to himself or anybody else. Violet Lynch received Tomasina's letter the morning of Wednesday, November 30. She read it to Timothy at the breakfast table before accusing him of lying.
然而，距离这位平时爱沟通的贝瑞尔联系她的公公婆婆已经过去近一个月了。托马西娜给布赖顿的贝瑞尔的父亲发了一封电报，因为她为杰拉丁买了一件裙子作为圣诞礼物，想在寄出之前确认贝瑞尔是否还在那里。在回信中，贝瑞尔的父亲透露他的女儿并没有和他住在一起。不久之后，托马西娜收到她的大嫂维奥莱特·林奇的信，告知她蒂莫西在默瑟维尔的家中度过了过去的两周。许多人告诉托马西娜，她的儿子欠他们钱，这导致她怀疑他逃避债务。托马西娜对蒂莫西撒谎并似乎抛弃了责任感到愤怒，于是回信给维奥莱特。她写道：“他身上有些谜团。你可以替我告诉他。只要我活着，我再也不想见到他了。他在这里辞掉了一份好工作。他就像他父亲一样。对自已对别人都没有好处。”维奥莱特·林奇在 11 月 30 日星期三早晨收到了托马西娜的信。她在餐桌上读给蒂莫西听，然后指责他在撒谎。
He maintained his story that Beryl and Geraldine were in Brighton. He also denied selling their furniture. He appeared anxious and didn't finish eating his meal. At 3.10 that afternoon, he walked into Murthervale's police station. Timothy told the officer on duty, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans, I would like to have a chat with you alone. He was taken into the station's charge office, where he announced, I want to give myself up. I have disposed of my wife. When asked what he meant, Timothy elaborated. I put her down the drain. The detective queried whether Timothy knew what he was admitting to. He answered, Yes, I know what I'm saying. I can't sleep and want to get it off my chest. He was cautioned and asked if he wanted to make a written statement. As he couldn't read or write, Timothy suggested he talk about it while officers dictated. He was then transferred five miles north to the criminal investigation department in his hometown of Murther Tidville.
他坚持他的说法，即贝瑞尔和杰拉丁在布赖顿。他还否认出卖了他们的家具。他显得很焦虑，没有吃完饭。那天下午 3 点 10 分，他走进了默瑟维尔的警察局。蒂莫西对值班警官、侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯说：“我想单独和您聊聊。”他被带到警察局的值班室，在那里他宣布：“我要自首。我处理掉了我的妻子。”当被问及这是什么意思时，蒂莫西详细解释道：“我把她扔进下水道了。”侦探询问蒂莫西是否知道自己在承认什么。他回答说：“是的，我知道我在说什么。我睡不着觉，想把它卸载心里。”他受到警告，并被问及是否想发表书面声明。由于他不会读写，蒂莫西建议他在警察口述时谈论此事。随后，他被向北转移了五英里，来到他家乡默瑟蒂德维尔的刑事调查部。
Once there, Timothy gave an official statement to Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans and another officer, Detective Sergeant Glindor Goff. He started with the discovery months earlier that Beryl was pregnant with their second child. The news distressed 19-year-old Beryl, who was already struggling to make ends meet with one child. She had also started a new job at a news agency and would have to quit if she had another baby. She wanted to terminate the pregnancy, but abortions were illegal in the United Kingdom at the time. Timothy didn't share his wife's concern, telling her, If you are having a baby, well, you've had one. Another one won't make any difference. Beryl said about trying to abort the pregnancy herself. Timothy warned that she would only end up making herself unwell, but Beryl was adamant.
到了那里，蒂莫西向侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯和另一名警官、侦探警长格林多·高夫作了正式声明。他从几个月前发现贝瑞尔怀上他们的第二个孩子开始讲起。这个消息让 19 岁的贝瑞尔感到苦恼，她带着一个孩子已经很难维持生计了。她还在一家新闻社找到了一份新工作，如果再生一个孩子就不得不辞职。她想终止妊娠，但在当时的英国堕胎是违法的。蒂莫西并不赞同他妻子的担忧，对她说：“如果你要生孩子，好吧，你已经生过一个了。再多一个也没有什么区别。”贝瑞尔谈到要自己尝试流产。蒂莫西警告说，她只会让自己生病，但贝瑞尔态度坚决。
Timothy approached his mother to see whether she knew of anything that could induce a miscarriage. As a practicing Catholic, Tomasina was firmly against the idea. Beryl also discussed the matter with Timothy's sisters, her brother, a friend, and her neighbors, John and Dethyl Christie. At the advice of those she spoke to, she obtained some over-the-counter pills and a syringe to inject glycerine and carboleic soap into her body, but her attempts failed. As time went on, the combination of her unhappy marriage, unwanted pregnancy, and other home remedies caused Beryl to become increasingly ill and emotionally distraught. She confided to her neighbor, Ethyl Christie, that she wanted to have an illegal abortion performed, but couldn't afford one. Then, in early November, Beryl's overall well-being appeared to improve. On Friday, November 4, her brother, Basil, noted that she seemed to be in good spirits, with upcoming plans to go on a holiday with baby Geraldine.
蒂莫西找到他的母亲，看她是否知道有什么东西可以诱发流产。作为一名虔诚的天主教徒，托马西娜坚决反对这个想法。贝瑞尔还与蒂莫西的姐妹、她的兄弟、一个朋友以及她的邻居约翰和黛瑟尔·克里斯特讨论了此事。在他们这些谈话对象的建议下，她买了一些非处方药和一个注射器，用于将甘油和石炭酸皂注入体内，但她的尝试失败了。随着时间的推移，不幸福的婚姻、意外怀孕以及其他民间偏方的结合，导致贝瑞尔的病情日益恶重，情绪也陷入崩溃。她向邻居埃瑟尔·克里斯特吐露，她想做非法堕胎，但负担不起。然后，在 11 月上旬，贝瑞尔的整体身体状况似乎有所改善。11 月 4 日星期五，她的兄弟巴西尔指出，她看起来精神很好，并有即将带着婴儿杰拉丁去度假的计划。
Yet, her husband told a different story. On Sunday, November 6, after a month of trying and failing to induce a miscarriage, Beryl told Timothy that if she couldn't have an abortion, then she would take her own life, as well as Geraldine's. The following morning, Timothy visited a cafe for breakfast. A man sitting nearby engaged him in conversation, asking, You were looking pretty worried. Is there anything on your mind? Timothy shared his troubles with the stranger, who in turn gave him a bottle wrapped in brown paper, stating, Tell your wife to take it first thing in the morning before she has any tea, then to lay down on the bed for a couple of hours, and that should do the job. That night, Beryl went to fetch a cigarette from her husband's coat pocket and discovered the bottle.
然而，她的丈夫却讲述了不同的故事。11 月 6 日星期日，在尝试了一个月却未能诱发流产后，贝瑞尔告诉蒂莫西，如果她不能流产，她将结束自己的生命以及杰拉丁的生命。第二天早上，蒂莫西去一家咖啡馆吃早餐。坐在附近的一名男子与他交谈，问他：“你看起来挺担心的。有什么心事吗？”蒂莫西与陌生人分享了他的烦恼，陌生人转而递给他一个用棕色纸包着的瓶子，并说道：“让你妻子在喝任何茶之前一清早就喝下它，然后躺在床上几个小时，这就行了。”那天晚上，贝瑞尔去从丈夫的外套口袋里拿香烟时发现了这个瓶子。
Timothy spoke of his encounter with the stranger at the cafe, but cautioned her not to consume the bottle's contents. He went to work the next day of Tuesday, November 8. Upon returning home in the evening, he noticed the flat was in darkness. Inside, he found Beryl in bed, deceased. Between 1 and 2 am, he dragged Beryl's body downstairs, out the front door, and lowered her head first into a storm drain. He then smoked a cigarette by the living room fire. Timothy claimed he didn't go to work the next day, and instead resigned, telling his employer that he had received a better offer. He visited his mother to tell her Beryl and Geraldine had gone to Brighton.
蒂莫西讲述了他与咖啡馆陌生人的偶遇，但警告她不要饮用瓶子里的东西。第二天（即 11 月 8 日星期二），他去上班了。晚上回家时，他发现公寓一片黑暗。在里面，他发现贝瑞尔在床上已经断气了。凌晨 1 点到 2 点之间，他把贝瑞尔的尸体拖到楼下，带出前门，把她头部朝下放进了一个雨水渠中。然后他在客厅的火炉旁抽了一支烟。蒂莫西声称他第二天没有去上班，而是辞职了，告诉雇主他收到了更好的报价。他去探望母亲，告诉她贝瑞尔和杰拉丁去了布赖顿。
He then arranged to have a second-hand furniture dealer purchase all of his furniture for £40. The dealer couldn't collect the items until Monday, November 14, so Timothy remained in London for the next five days. Afterwards, he caught a train to Wales to visit his aunt and uncle in Murthervale. He told the officers that he had arranged for someone to look after baby Geraldine before departing. Timothy concluded his statement at 5.10 pm, at which point it was read back to him and he signed it. Three officers were dispatched to 10 Rillington Place, where they spotted a storm drain in the street out front, as Timothy described. Even with their combined strength, they were unable to lift its heavy cover. Their efforts drew the attention of ground floor resident John Christie, who emerged from his flat and re-affirmed that Beryl and Geraldine had left some time ago.
然后他安排了一名二手家具商以 40 英镑的价格购买了他所有的家具。家具商直到 11 月 14 日星期一才能收走这些物品，因此蒂莫西在伦敦又呆了五天。之后，他坐火车去威尔士拜访了他在默瑟维尔的叔叔和阿姨。他告诉警官们，他在离开前已经安排好让人照顾婴儿杰拉丁。蒂莫西在下午 5 点 10 分结束了他的声明，随后该声明被读给他听并且他签了字。三名警官被派往灵顿街 10 号，正如蒂莫西所描述的那样，他们在正前方的街道上发现了一个雨水渠。尽管他们合力，却无法举起沉重的井盖。他们的努力引起了底层居民约翰·克里斯特的注意，他从公寓里走出来，再次确认贝瑞尔和杰拉丁不久前已经离开了。
Through the use of levers, the officers were finally able to lift the storm drain lid. They peered inside, only to find it empty. At approximately 9 pm, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans returned to where Timothy Evans was being held and told him, the drain which you say you put your wife's body down has been examined and there is nothing there. He replied, well, I put it there. When asked who helped him lift the cover, Timothy stated that he had done so entirely by himself. Given its weight, the detective was skeptical and remarked, I don't think that your wife's body has ever been in the drain. Timothy responded, no, I said that to protect a man named Christie.
通过使用杠杆，警官们终于能够撬开雨水渠盖。他们往里面张望，结果发现里面空无一人。大约晚上 9 点，侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯回到关押蒂莫西·埃文斯的地点并告诉他：“你声称把妻子尸体扔进去的下水道已经检查过了，里面什么也没有。”他回答说：“好吧，我把它放在那儿了。”当被问及是谁帮他抬起盖子时，蒂莫西声称那是他自己一个人完全做到的。鉴于其重量，侦探持怀疑态度并评论道：“我认为你妻子的尸体根本就没有在下水道里。”蒂莫西回应说：“没有，我那样说是为了保护一个叫克里斯特的人。”
It's not true about the man in the cafe either. I'll tell you the truth now. He then proceeded to give a second statement which the officers transcribed. He admitted to lying about meeting a stranger in a cafe, but maintained the rest of his statement was essentially true. Roughly a week before Beryl had died, Timothy was approached by his downstairs neighbour, John Christie. John, who was aware of Beryl's attempts to terminate her pregnancy, remarked, I'd like to have a chat with you about your wife taking these tablets. I know what she's taking them for, she's trying to get rid of the baby.
关于咖啡馆里那个人的事也不是真的。我现在把真相告诉你。随后，他接着做出了第二份声明，警官们将其记录了下来。他承认关于在咖啡馆遇到陌生人的事是撒谎，但坚称他声明的其余部分基本属实。在贝瑞尔去世前大约一周，蒂莫西被楼下的邻居约翰·克里斯特搭讪。约翰深知贝瑞尔终止妊娠的企图，评论道：“我想和你谈谈你妻子吃这些药的事。我知道她在吃这些药是为了什么，她想摆脱这个孩子。”
If you or your wife had come to me in the first place, I could have done it for you without any risk. John revealed that he had been studying to be a doctor prior to the outbreak of World War One and showed Timothy a medical textbook he owned. Timothy was unable to read it, but it contained diagrams and illustrations of the human anatomy. John said he could perform an abortion, but cautioned there was a one in ten chance Beryl would die. Timothy was disinterested in the offer and went upstairs to his flat. When he entered, Beryl immediately asked whether John Christie had spoken to him about performing an abortion. Timothy said he had, but told Beryl she wasn't to have anything to do with it. As she trusted John, she intended to take him up on his offer.
如果你或你妻子一开始就来找我，我本可以毫无风险地为你做这件事。约翰透露，他在第一次世界大战爆发前曾研究过当医生，并向蒂莫西展示了他拥有的一本医学教科书。蒂莫西看不懂，但书中有关于人体解剖学的图表和插图。约翰说他可以进行堕胎手术，但警告说贝瑞尔有十分之一的死亡几率。蒂莫西对这个提议不感兴趣，便上楼回了自己的公寓。他一进门，贝瑞尔立刻问约翰·克里斯特有没有跟他谈过做流产手术的事。蒂莫西说他谈过了，但告诉贝瑞尔她绝对不能参与此事。由于她信任约翰，她打算接受他的提议。
Several days later, on Monday, November 7, Timothy arrived home from work and was told by Beryl that John Christie had made arrangements to carry out the procedure the next morning. Shortly before her husband left for work the following morning, Beryl asked him to tell John on his way out that everything was all right to proceed. She threatened to tell him herself if Timothy didn't. Timothy did as he was asked, then went to work. When he returned home that evening, John Christie was waiting for him at the bottom of the staircase. He followed Timothy upstairs and told him. It's bad news. It didn't work. Timothy entered his flat and found his wife's body on their bed covered with a quilt.
几天后的 11 月 7 日星期一，蒂莫西下班回家，贝瑞尔告诉他，约翰·克里斯特已经安排在第二天早上实施手术。就在丈夫第二天早上出门上班前不久，贝瑞尔要求他在出门的路上告诉约翰一切顺利，可以继续进行。她威胁说，如果蒂莫西不去，她就自己去告诉他。蒂莫西照办了，然后去上班。那天晚上他回到家时，约翰·克里斯特正等在楼梯底部。他跟着蒂莫西上楼并告诉他：“是个坏消息。没成功。”蒂莫西走进公寓，发现妻子的尸体盖着一条被子躺在他们的床上。
He uncovered her, seeing that she was dressed in a black skirt, her checked blouse and a light blue jacket. There was blood around her mouth and nose and between her legs. Geraldine was nearby in her cot. Timothy picked her up, wrapped her in a blanket and took her into the kitchen where John Christie was waiting. He said Beryl had been dead since about 3 o'clock, adding that her stomach had been septic poisoned and that she would have had to go to the hospital anyway. He refused to give any details about the failed abortion procedure or what had involved. For the past month, the middle floor flat at 10 Rillington Place had been unoccupied. Its sole resident, an elderly man named Charles Kitchener, had been hospitalized to undergo an operation on his eyes.
他揭开被子，看到她穿着一条黑裙子、格子衬衫和一件浅蓝色夹克。她的嘴、鼻子周围以及两腿之间有血迹。杰拉丁就在附近的婴儿床里。蒂莫西抱起她，用毯子把她裹起来，带到约翰·克里斯特正在等候的厨房。他说贝瑞尔大约在 3 点钟就已经死了，并补充说她的胃已经感染中毒，无论如何她都得去医院。他拒绝透露任何关于失败的流产手术的细节或手术过程。过去一个月里，灵顿街 10 号的中层公寓一直空置。其唯一的居民、一位名叫查尔斯·基奇纳的老人因眼睛做手术而住院。
John Christie took Beryl's body into the vacant flat and promised to dispose of it later down a nearby drain. Timothy remarked that it was foolish to dispose of Beryl's body, but John said it was necessary to prevent police prosecuting him for performing an illegal medical procedure. He instructed Timothy to go to work as per usual in the morning while he looked after baby Geraldine, as suspicions might arise if she was sent to her grandmother's home unexpectedly. Over the next few days, John urged Timothy to leave London as soon as possible in order to conceal the death of his wife. He recommended a local furniture dealer Timothy could sell his belongings to and said he knew a young couple in the nearby area of East Acton who would be happy to look after Geraldine. Timothy did as he was told, and while he was at work on Thursday, November 10, John had the young couple come by to collect Geraldine. Timothy told his relatives that his wife and daughter were on holiday, as instructed by John, and disposed of Beryl's clothing by tearing it up into pieces and giving them to a rag dealer. Once his personal affairs were in order and the flat was empty, he caught a train to Murthervale.
约翰·克里斯特把贝瑞尔的尸体搬进了空公寓，并承诺稍后将其处理在附近的一个下水道里。蒂莫西评论说处理掉贝瑞尔的尸体是愚蠢的，但约翰说这是必要的，以防警方因他实施非法医疗程序而起诉他。他指示蒂莫西早上像往常一样去上班，而他则照顾婴儿杰拉丁，因为如果把她意外送到祖母家可能会引起怀疑。在接下来的几天里，约翰敦促蒂莫西尽快离开伦敦，以掩盖他妻子的死讯。他推荐了一位蒂莫西可以把物品卖给他的当地家具商，并说他认识附近东阿克顿地区的一对年轻夫妇，他们很乐意照顾杰拉丁。蒂莫西照做了，当他在 11 月 10 日星期四上班时，约翰让这对年轻夫妇顺道来接走了杰拉丁。蒂莫西按照约翰的指示告诉亲戚他的妻子和女儿去度假了，并通过将贝瑞尔的衣服撕成碎片并送给破烂商来处理掉了它们。一旦个人事务料理完毕且公寓空了，他便乘火车前往默瑟维尔。
By the time Timothy concluded giving this second statement, it was 11.50pm. He had been in police custody for almost nine hours and spent the remainder of the night in solitary confinement. Both John and Ethel Christie were questioned at length in relation to Timothy's accusations. John denied offering to perform an abortion on Beryl that had been aware she was trying to terminate an unwanted pregnancy. He advised her against it for the sake of her health. Ethel told police that Beryl mentioned going to a location near a hospital where she could pay to have an abortion carried out. The Christie's described the Evans' marriage as an unhappy one, with John explaining, quote, Beryl has told my wife and I on more than one occasion that Timothy has assaulted her and grabbed hold of her throat. She said he has a violent temper and one time would do her in. John had spent the first two weeks of November practically housebound after taking time off from the factory where he worked due to ill health. On the date of Beryl's alleged death, he was at home suffering severe back pain and inflammation of the small intestine.
当蒂莫西完成这第二份声明时，已经是晚上 11 点 50 分了。他已经被警方拘留了近九个小时，并在单人牢房里度过了当晚的剩余时间。约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯特都就蒂莫西的指控接受了详细盘问。约翰否认曾主动提出为贝瑞尔做流产手术，并否认知道她试图终止意外怀孕。为了她的健康，他曾劝阻她不要这样做。埃瑟尔告诉警察，贝瑞尔曾提过去一家医院附近的地方，她可以在那里付钱做人工流产。克里斯特夫妇将埃文斯夫妇的婚姻描述为不幸的婚姻，约翰解释说：“贝瑞尔不止一次地对我和妻子说过，蒂莫西曾对她施暴并掐住她的喉咙。她说他脾气暴躁，有一次差点把她弄死。”由于身体健康不佳，约翰在工厂请假后，在 11 月的前两周几乎足不出户。在贝瑞尔据称死亡的那天，他因为严重的背痛和小肠炎症而呆在家。
He left his flat twice to see the doctor at 5.20pm and to visit the library with his wife. John saw Beryl for the last time that day as she left the house. At 7 o'clock that evening, Timothy returned home and spoke to the Christie's, telling them that Beryl and Geraldine had gone to the city of Bristol to visit friends and he would join them later in the week. Almost a week later on Monday, November 14, Timothy told John that he had quit his job and was moving. Before his departure, Timothy gave his neighbour two suitcases as well as Geraldine's pram and high chair, asking him to hold onto them until he found a new home for his family. He reappeared almost 10 days later on Wednesday, November 23. John said that his wife had inquired about Beryl, at which point Timothy revealed that she had left him. Police also spoke with Timothy's mother, who confirmed she hadn't seen her son, his wife, or their child in weeks.
他离开公寓两次去看医生（下午 5 点 20 分）以及和妻子去图书馆。约翰那天最后一次见到贝瑞尔是在她离开房子的时候。那天晚上 7 点，蒂莫西回到家，与克里斯特夫妇交谈，告诉他们贝瑞尔和杰拉丁已经去了布里斯托尔市看望朋友，他将在本周晚些时候去和她们会合。将近一周后的 11 月 14 日星期一，蒂莫西告诉约翰他已经辞职并准备搬家。在离开前，蒂莫西把两个手提箱以及杰拉丁的婴儿车和高脚椅交给了邻居，请他帮忙保管，直到他为家人找到新家。大约 10 天后的 11 月 23 日星期三，他又出现了。约翰说他的妻子曾打听过贝瑞尔的下落，这时蒂莫西才透露她已经抛弃了他。警察还与蒂莫西的母亲交谈，她证实她几周来都没见过她的儿子、儿媳或他们的孩子。
They passed on a message from Timothy, asking her to contact John Christie to confirm the address of the young couple who had Geraldine. His message didn't make sense to Thomasina, who replied, I know my son has a very vivid imagination and is a terrible liar. Timothy's personal belongings were retrieved from the Murthervale home of Cornelius and Violet Lynch, including the letter his mother sent days earlier, conveying her frustrations that he had abandoned his family. Afterwards, Detective Constable Gwynfren Evans spoke with Timothy Evans again, who feigned ignorance over the letter penned by his mother. He was asked when he last saw Beryl's body and whether he had helped John Christie move it to Charles Kitchener's middle floor flat. Here, Timothy changed his story yet again. He claimed he had heard his 50-year-old neighbour huffing and puffing as he struggled to drag his wife's body downstairs.
他们转达了蒂莫西的信息，要求她联系约翰·克里斯特以确认收留杰拉丁的那对年轻夫妇的地址。他的信息对托马西娜来说毫无意义，她回复道：“我知道我的儿子有着非常生动的想象力，是个极度说谎者。”蒂莫西的个人物品从科尼利厄斯和维奥莱特·林奇位于默瑟维尔的家中取回，其中包括他母亲几天前寄出的信，信中表达了他抛弃家庭的愤怒。随后，侦探警员格温弗伦·埃文斯再次与蒂莫西·埃文斯交谈，他装作不知道他母亲写的这封信。他被问及最后一次见到贝瑞尔的尸体是什么时候，以及他是否帮约翰·克里斯特把它搬到查尔斯·基奇纳的中层公寓。在这里，蒂莫西又一次改变了说法。他声称他听到他 50 岁的邻居气喘吁吁地挣扎着把妻子尸体拖下楼。
He had then assisted by carrying her legs while John lifted her torso. Quote, That's the truth, and that's the last time I saw her body. When asked if he had returned to London after fleeing to Murthervale, Timothy responded, Oh yes, I forgot about that. He claimed to have returned to inquire about Geraldine's welfare, but John Christie had told him he couldn't visit his daughter for another two or three weeks as she was still settling in to her new home. Detective Evans expressed his disbelief at Timothy's story, prompting the response, I may have made a few mistakes, but as far as Christie is concerned, I have said the truth. Meanwhile, a search of 10 Rillington Place was underway.
然后他帮忙抬着她的腿，而约翰则抬着她的躯干。“千真万确，那是最后一次我见到她的尸体。”当被问及逃到默瑟维尔后是否回过伦敦时，蒂莫西回答说：“哦，对，我把这事给忘了。”他声称自己回去打听杰拉丁的近况，但约翰·克里斯特告诉他，因为她还在适应新家，所以还要再等两三周才能去看望女儿。埃文斯侦探对蒂莫西的说法表示难以置信，这引来了这样的回应：“我可能犯了一些错误，但就克里斯特而言，我说的都是实话。”与此同时，对灵顿街 10 号的搜查正在进行中。
Police examined the garden for recently disturbed earth, but found nothing. In the ground floor flat belonging to John and Ethel Christie, police found Geraldine's clothing, pram and high chair. The Evans' upstairs flat was empty of furniture, but four newspaper clippings were discovered. They detailed a notorious crime that had taken place earlier that autumn. On October 4, 1949, Stanley Setty, a wealthy car dealer from London's East End, disappeared. Nearly three weeks later, his torso was found in a marsh in the nearby county of Essex. A 29-year-old named Brian Hume was later charged with the murder. The clippings included pictures of the bundle that Stanley's torso had been wrapped in.
警察检查了花园里最近被翻动过的泥土，但一无所获。在约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂夫妇的底楼公寓里，警察发现了杰拉尔丁的衣物、婴儿车和高脚椅。埃文斯楼上的公寓里空无家具，但人们发现了四篇剪报。它们详细报道了当年秋天早些时候发生的一起轰动一时的罪案。1949年10月4日，伦敦东区的一位富有的汽车经销商斯坦利·塞蒂失踪了。近三周后，人们在附近埃塞克斯郡的一个沼泽里发现了他的躯干。一名29岁名叫布赖恩·休姆的男子随后被指控谋杀。这些剪报包括斯坦利躯干被包裹着的包裹的照片。
Officers also found a briefcase that had been stolen in August from a residential Notting Hill address, enabling them to arrest Timothy Evans for grand larceny. By the morning of Friday, December 2, more than 36 hours had passed since Timothy Evans had given his initial confession, yet police still hadn't found Beryl or Geraldine. Timothy remained insistent that John Christie had killed Beryl and had knowledge of Geraldine's whereabouts, but John staunchly denied these claims. By this stage, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings had been placed in charge of the case. Another officer and a biologist from Scotland Yard joined him in a thorough search of Tan-Rillington Place.
警官们还发现了一个公文包，该公文包是8月份从诺丁山的一处住宅地址被盗的，这使得他们能够以重大盗窃罪逮捕蒂姆·埃文斯。到12月2日星期五早晨，距离蒂姆·埃文斯做出最初的供认已经过去了36个多小时，然而警察仍然没有找到贝里尔或杰拉尔丁。蒂姆坚称是约翰·克里斯蒂杀害了贝里尔，并且知道杰拉尔丁的下落，但约翰坚决否认这些说法。此时，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯已被派来负责此案。苏格兰场的一名警官和一名生物学家加入了他，对坦林顿广场10号进行了彻底搜查。
The house was again checked from top to bottom, but resulted in no significant discoveries. They went into the communal backyard next, finding a broken dustbin that didn't garner their interest. They searched the outdoor lavatory before turning their attention to the small wash house that had joined it, though the door stuck shut. Ethel Christie, who was observing the goings-on with her husband, explained that the door had a habit of jamming and fetched a knife which was used to prise it open. It was so dark inside that the officers needed a torch to see. The wash house measured just 54 by 52 inches and was primarily used for storage or fetching water. There was a copper boiler in the left corner and to the right was a sink with a pile of timber boards stacked against it.
这栋房子再次被彻底搜查，但没有得出任何重大的发现。接着他们走进了隔壁共用的后院，发现了一个破损的垃圾桶，这并没有引起他们的兴趣。他们在搜查了室外厕所后，将注意力转向了与之相连的小洗衣房，尽管门被卡死了。埃塞尔·克里斯蒂和她的丈夫一起观察着事态的发展，她解释说这门有卡壳的习惯，并取来一把小刀将它撬开。里面太黑了，警官们需要手电筒才能看清。洗衣房面积仅为54乘52英寸，主要用于储藏或取水。左角有一个铜制锅炉，右边是一个水槽，靠着一堆木板。
Chief Detective Inspector Jennings reached behind the wood pile and felt something. He removed some of the boards and uncovered something wrapped in a green tablecloth and tied with a cotton sash cord. He asked Ethel what was in it, but she had never seen it before. The officers laid the bundle on the cement outside the wash house. As they did so, a pair of feet that were bound together slipped out. Detective Jennings returned to the wash house and spotted something else hidden behind some wood stacked behind the door. It was the body of a baby girl with a man's tie knotted around her neck. You could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now.
侦探总督察詹宁斯伸手到木堆后面摸到了什么。他移开了一些木板，发现了一个用绿色桌布包裹、用棉质饰带绳捆绑的东西。他问埃塞尔里面是什么，但她从未见过这东西。警官们把包裹放在洗衣房外的水泥地上。当他们这样做时，一双绑在一起的脚滑了出来。詹宁斯侦探回到洗衣房，发现门后堆放的木头后面还藏着别的东西。那是一个女婴的尸体，脖子上系着一个男士领带结。你现在可能正坐在完美的爱彼迎（Airbnb）住所里。
If you have a spare bedroom, which is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world, if you're hosting them, why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am, it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place. I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo just sitting there not being used. And I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host. When I'm traveling the world, I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb's because I like having access to a kitchen, feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling, having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home.
如果你有一间空置的卧室，这不仅是结识来自世界各地的新朋友的有趣方式，如果你在招待他们的话，为什么不顺便赚点外快呢？或者如果你像我一样经常旅行，把你的整个房子租给爱彼迎是多么容易啊。去年我一年中有四个月不在城里，空置的公寓就摆在那里没用。我意识到，只要成为一名爱彼迎房东，就能轻松地在业余时间赚取外快，来支付我外出时的所有旅行费用。当我环游世界时，我几乎只住在爱彼迎，因为我喜欢可以使用厨房，旅行时有在家的感觉，并拥有你在家里通常会有的所有东西。
And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide, so you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it. I just used Airbnb actually in Tulum to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have ever seen. It was such a vibe, the aesthetic was incredible, the service was fantastic, and I loved the privacy of it. Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income, whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere, or just trying to cover bills and passively bump up your income. Your home might be worth more than you think.
我喜欢许多房东提供的当地推荐指南，这样你就可以通过一个真正在这里生活过的人来了解你正在访问的地区。我其实刚刚在图卢姆使用过爱彼迎，住在我见过的最豪华的顶层阁楼里。这里的氛围太棒了，美学令人难以置信，服务非常出色，而且我喜欢它的私密性。爱彼迎是一种利用你现有的东西来创造更多收入的绝佳方式，无论你是在为婚礼或某次大旅行存钱，还是只是试图支付账单并被动地增加收入。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。
So find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host. The large, bound parcel contained the body of 19-year-old Beryl Evans, bent with her head between her feet. The infant body was that of her one-year-old daughter, Geraldine. As the weather in London had been cold in recent weeks, both corpses were preserved and had no foul odor. Beryl and Geraldine had been deceased for roughly three weeks, and the cause of death in both cases was asphyxiation by strangulation. Ligature marks and bruises on Beryl's throat and neck were consistent with her killer using a piece of rope or twisted stocking.
因此，请访问 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。那个大而捆绑的包裹里装着19岁的贝里尔·埃文斯的尸体，她的头弯在双脚之间。婴儿的尸体是她一岁的女儿杰拉尔丁。由于伦敦最近几周天气寒冷，两具尸体都得到了保存，没有散发恶臭。贝里尔和杰拉尔丁已经去世大约三周，两人的死因都是勒颈窒息。贝里尔喉部和颈部的勒痕和瘀伤与凶手使用绳子或扭曲的长筒袜相符。
She was dressed in a skirt, blouse and jacket, with the latter two undone, exposing her upper body. Her underwear was missing. Her face was bruised with her right eye and upper lip both swollen, indicating that she'd been struck about 20 minutes before her death. Beryl also had two bruises on her upper left thigh, one on her left shin, and another small bruise inside her vaginal wall. Her womb contained a 16-week-old male fetus and bore no signs of the work of an amateur abortionist. It was believed that the bruise in her vagina might have been from a self-inflicted injury done to induce a miscarriage,
她穿着裙子、衬衫和夹克，后两件没有系扣，露出了上身。她的内衣不见了。她的脸部有瘀伤，右眼和上唇都肿了，这表明她在死前约20分钟遭到过击打。贝里尔的左大腿上部还有两处瘀伤，左小腿有一处，阴道壁内部还有一处小瘀伤。她的子宫里有一个16周大的男胎，没有人工流产手术的痕迹。人们认为她阴道内的瘀伤可能是为了诱发流产而造成的自我伤害，
yet the possibility that her killer had attempted to sexually assault her post-mortem was also considered. Geraldine Evans was fully clothed. Her only injuries were ligature marks on her neck, caused by the tie found with her remains. The pair's clothing was identified by John and death or Christie, who confirmed the items had belonged to their neighbors. When shown the tie used to kill Geraldine, John thought he might have seen Timothy Evans wearing one quite similar. Timothy Evans was transported from Mertha Tidville back to London so that he could be formally charged with the murder of Beryl and Geraldine. Without telling him that the bodies of his wife and daughter had been found, the officers escorted Timothy on a train to London that night. A police tip-off alerted the media, and a press photographer was waiting as the train pulled in at Paddington Station.
然而，凶手曾试图在她死后对其实施性侵犯的可能性也被考虑在内。杰拉尔丁·埃文斯穿戴整齐。她唯一的伤势是脖子上的勒痕，是由与她的遗体一起发现的领带造成的。两人的衣物被约翰和克里斯蒂（死者）辨认出来，他们确认这些物品属于他们的邻居。当被展示用于杀害杰拉尔丁的领带时，约翰认为他可能见过蒂姆·埃文斯戴过一条非常相似的领带。蒂姆·埃文斯被从默瑟蒂德维尔押回伦敦，以便对其实施对贝里尔和杰拉尔丁谋杀罪的正式起诉。在没有告诉他妻女尸体已被发现的情况下，警官们当晚用火车押送蒂姆前往伦敦。警方的一条线索惊动了媒体，当火车驶入帕丁顿车站时，一名新闻摄影记者正在那里等待。
They snapped a picture of a startled and distraught Timothy as he disembarked, flanked by two officers. He was taken to Notting Hill Police Station, where he was placed in the charge room. Layed out on the floor were the items recovered from Beryl and Geraldine's bodies, including their clothing, the blanket, tablecloth and cord used to wrap Beryl's body, and the knotted tie used to strangle Geraldine. As Timothy surveyed the items, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings stated, At 11.50 today I found the dead body of your wife, Beryl Evans, concealed in a wash house at 10 Rillington Place, Notting Hill. Also, the body of your baby daughter, Geraldine, concealed behind some timber in the same outbuilding, and this clothing was found with them. Tears appeared in Timothy's eyes. As he picked up the tie, Detective Jennings informed him that his wife and daughter had been strangled to death, and that he had reason to believe Timothy was responsible. Timothy replied, Yes.
他们抓拍到了一张惊恐而心烦意乱的蒂姆的照片，当时他下了车，两名警官在一旁护送。他被带到诺丁山警察局，并被安置在值班室里。地板上摆放着从贝里尔和杰拉尔丁尸体上取下的物品，包括她们的衣服、用于包裹贝里尔尸体的毯子、桌布和绳子，以及用于勒死杰拉尔丁的打结领带。当蒂姆审视这些物品时，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯说道：“今天11点50分，我在诺丁山里灵顿广场10号的一间洗衣房里发现了你妻子贝里尔·埃文斯的尸体。还有你婴儿女儿杰拉尔丁的尸体，藏在同一个附属建筑的一些木材后面，这些衣服是在她们身边发现的。”蒂姆的眼中泛起了泪水。当他拿起领带时，詹宁斯侦探告诉他，他的妻子和女儿是被勒死的，并且他有理由相信蒂姆应当负责。蒂姆回答说：“是的。”
Timothy immediately provided a brief, verbal confession to the crimes, which Detective Jennings transcribed into his notebook. It read, Beryl was incurring one death after another. I could not stand it any longer, so I strangled her with a piece of rope, and took her down to the flat below the same night, whilst the old man was in hospital. I waited till the Christie's downstairs had gone to bed, then I took her to the wash house after midnight. This was on Tuesday 8th November. On Thursday evening, after I came home from work, I strangled my baby in our bedroom with my tie, and later that night I took her down into the wash house after the Christie's had gone to bed. When Timothy signed this confession, he allegedly told the officers he felt a great relief at finally sharing the truth, before offering to go into more detail about the crimes. He then provided another, more detailed statement, his fourth since turning himself in to police two days earlier. He described murdering Beryl around 6.30 on the evening of Tuesday, November 8, after she initiated a dispute that quickly became physical.
蒂姆随即对罪行进行了简短的口头供述，詹宁斯侦探将其记录在笔记本上。上面写着：“贝里尔祸不单行，一个接一个地死。我再也忍受不下去了，于是我用一根绳子勒死了她，并在当晚老头子住院时，把她带到了楼下的公寓。我等到楼下的克里斯蒂夫妇上床睡觉后，在午夜过后把她带到了洗衣房。这是在11月8日星期二。周四晚上，我下班回家后，在我们的卧室里用我的领带勒死了我的孩子，那天深夜，等克里斯蒂夫妇上床睡觉后，我把她带到了洗衣房。”当蒂姆签署这份供词时，据称他告诉警官，在终于说出真相后，他感到如释重负，随后提出要详细讲述这些罪行。接着，他又提供了一份更详细的陈述，这是他两天前自首以来的第四份陈述。他描述了在11月8日星期二傍晚6点30分左右谋杀贝里尔的过程，当时贝里尔挑起了一场很快升级为肢体冲突的争吵。
Timothy hid her across the face, and Beryl retaliated. Quote, In a fit of temper, I grabbed a piece of rope from a chair which I had brought home off my van, and strangled her with it. I then took her into the bedroom and laid her on the bed, with the rope still tied around her neck. Before 10 that night, I carried my wife's body downstairs to the kitchen of Mr Kitchener's flat, as I knew he was away in hospital. He then fed Geraldine, put her to bed, and smoked a cigarette, before returning to Charles Kitchener's vacant flat to wrap Beryl's body in a blanket and green tablecloth. He bound her concealed body with cord from a kitchen cupboard, and carried her downstairs to the wash house. She was placed under the sink, with planks of wood stacked in front. Timothy then slipped back into the house, and spent the rest of the night lying fully dressed on his bed.
蒂姆打了贝里尔的脸，贝里尔进行了回击。引述：“在一时冲动下，我从一把椅子上抓起了一段我从面包车上带回家的绳子，并用它勒死了她。然后我把她带进卧室，放在床上，绳子仍然系在她脖子上。那天晚上10点之前，我把我妻子的尸体搬到了楼下基奇纳先生公寓的厨房里，因为我知道他住院不在家。”接着他喂了杰拉尔丁，让她上床睡觉，抽了一根烟，然后回到查尔斯·基奇纳空置的公寓里，用毯子和绿色桌布把贝里尔的尸体包裹起来。他用厨房橱柜里的绳子捆绑了她被包裹的尸体，并把它搬到了楼下的洗衣房。她被放在水槽下面，前面堆着木板。随后蒂姆溜回屋里，在床上穿着衣服躺着度过了剩下的夜晚。
Over the next two days, he fed and changed Geraldine before going to work, leaving her alone at the flat until he returned in the evenings. On Wednesday, November 10, he had an argument with his employer, and subsequently quit. Upon arriving home, he picked up Geraldine from her cot, and strangled her with one of his tires. After waiting for John and Ethel Christie to go to bed, he crept downstairs with the Geraldine's body, and hid her in the wash house as well. News of Evan's arrest broke quickly. On Saturday, December 3, two London papers published stories about his late night interrogation, with the evening standard running a headline that read, Man All Night with the Police. That same morning, Timothy was formally charged with murder, to which he replied,
在接下来的两天里，他喂养并照顾杰拉尔丁，然后去上班，把她一个人留在公寓里，直到傍晚回来。11月10日星期三，他和雇主发生了争吵，随后辞职了。回到家后，他把杰拉尔丁从婴儿床里抱起来，用自己的一条轮胎勒死了她。在等待约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂上床睡觉后，他带着杰拉尔丁的尸体悄悄下楼，也将她藏在了洗衣房里。埃文斯被捕的消息迅速传开。12月3日星期六，两家伦敦报纸报道了他深夜审讯的故事，其中《标准晚报》的头条写道：“男子与警方共度整夜”。当天上午，蒂姆被正式指控谋杀，对此他回答：
Yes, that's right. He was transported to Brixton Prison in London's Inner South to await trial. Upon admission, he confessed to the prison's principal medical officer, who was required to ascertain whether he was sane and mentally competent to stand trial. For reasons unknown, Beryl's father and siblings were not given details regarding her and Geraldine's funeral. Authorities arranged for the mother and daughter to be laid to rest in a shared grave, known as a porpoise grave, alongside six other bodies. Their burial site was located in the Catholic section of London's Gunnersbury Cemetery, despite Beryl being of Jewish faith. In the days that followed, investigators set about building a case for the prosecution. They revisited 10 Rillington Place on Monday, December 5, to obtain a more detailed statement from residents John and Ethel Christie.
“是的，没错。”他被运送到伦敦南部内陆的布里克斯顿监狱等待审判。入狱后，他向监狱的主治医师供认了罪行，该医师负责确定他是否精神健全且具有接受审判的精神能力。出于未知的原因，贝里尔的父亲和兄弟姐妹没有得到关于她和杰拉尔丁葬礼的详细信息。当局安排这对母女安葬在一个合葬墓中，被称为鼠海豚墓，旁边还有另外六具尸体。她们的墓地位于伦敦冈纳斯伯里公墓的天主教区，尽管贝里尔信仰犹太教。在随后的几天里，调查人员着手为起诉建立案卷。他们在12月5日星期日再次访问里灵顿广场10号，以从居民约翰和埃塞尔·克里斯蒂那里获得更详细的陈述。
Both reported hearing heavy thudding from above on the night of November 8, as though someone were moving furniture. In relation to the backyard wash house, Ethel told police that they locked its door each night. However, there was no lock on the door, with residents merely jamming it shut in a manner that made it difficult to open. As the room's boiler was broken, the space was typically used for storage. Ethel had been using it daily since November 8 to rinse out a bedpan and saw the pile of timber stacked in front of the sink, but didn't notice anything tucked behind it. John Christie didn't visit the wash house until Monday, November 14, the date Timothy Evans left for Wales. At 7.30 that morning, John ventured out to fetch some firewood. He entered the wash house and noticed the timber pile, but didn't disturb it.
两人都报告说，在11月8日晚上，听到楼上传来沉闷的撞击声，好像有人在搬家具。关于后院洗衣房，埃塞尔告诉警察，他们每天晚上都锁上门。然而，门上并没有锁，居民们只是用一种难以打开的方式把它卡死。由于房间里的锅炉坏了，这个空间通常被用作储藏室。自11月8日以来，埃塞尔每天都使用它来冲洗便盆，并看到了堆在水槽前的木材堆，但没有注意到藏在它后面的任何东西。直到11月14日星期一，即蒂姆·埃文斯动身前往威尔士的那天，约翰才去过洗衣房。那天早上7点30分，约翰冒险出去取一些柴火。他走进洗衣房，注意到了木材堆，但没有动它。
The day before Beryl was murdered, she spoke to Ethel about a friend named Joan Vincent coming to visit. Beryl was less than enthused, accusing the woman of causing trouble between herself and Timothy. Joan was one of Beryl's oldest friends, having met in school when they were children. They lost touch, only to reconnect after a chance meeting at a post-ponatal clinic where they took their infant daughters. The two women would catch up several times a week, taking it in turns to visit one another. Joan told police that she couldn't quite recall when she had last visited Beryl, naming November 5, 7 and 8 as possible dates. Joan arrived at 10 Rillington Place around lunchtime. The building's front door was open, something she had never seen before.
在贝里尔被谋杀的前一天，她对埃塞尔谈到一个名叫琼·文森特的朋友要来探望。贝里尔对此并不热心，指责这个女人在自己和蒂姆之间挑拨离间。琼是贝里尔的老朋友之一，她们在童年上学时就认识了。她们失去了联系，直到在一家产后诊所偶然相遇后才重新建立联系，当时她们带着各自的婴儿女儿。这两个女人每周会聚几次，轮流拜访对方。琼告诉警方，她记不清自己最后一次拜访贝里尔是什么时候了，并列举了11月5日、7日和8日作为可能的日期。琼在午餐时间左右到达里灵顿广场10号。这栋建筑的前门是开着的，这是她从未见过的。
She went upstairs and found the door to the Evans' flat, which was usually kept open, closed. She knocked and called out, Beryl, it's me. There was no answer, which Joan found odd as Beryl was always home at lunchtime. She attempted to open the door by turning the handle. It gave slightly before closing again as though someone were pushing against it. Convinced there was somebody standing on the other side, Joan said, If you don't want to see me, you've only got to say so. There was no reply, so Joan left.
她上楼发现埃文斯家公寓的门通常是开着的，但现在却关着。她敲门并喊道：“贝里尔，是我。”没有任何回应，琼觉得这很奇怪，因为贝里尔午餐时间总是在家。她试图通过转动把手来开门。门稍微松了一下，然后又关上了，就像有人在里面推着一样。确信里面有人站着，琼说：“如果你不想见我，直说就行了。”没有任何回复，于是琼离开了。
In the course of their investigation, police discovered that around the time of Beryl's murder, structural work was underway at 10 Rillington Place. The landlord had hired a team of five laborers to repair plastering and replace floorboards. A manager, plasterer, carpenter and two assistants commenced work on Monday, October 31 and were at the property on and off over the next two weeks. Repair work on the roof of the outdoor wash house and lavatory commenced on Tuesday, November 8. Plasterer Frederick Willis and his assistant Frederick Jones left the building's front door open as they were constantly entering and exiting to gather equipment. At around 10am, Jones was mixing materials out front when a young woman came downstairs with a baby in her arms, accompanied by another young woman. She put the baby in a pram and left. He couldn't recall seeing her again. The plasterers finished mending the wash house ceiling by the following day and for the rest of the week were regularly in and out of the small building as they stored their tools in there.
在调查过程中，警察发现，在贝里尔被谋杀前后，里灵顿广场10号正在进行结构施工。房东雇佣了由五名工人组成的团队来修补灰泥和更换地板。一名经理、一名泥瓦匠、一名木匠和两名助手于10月31日星期一开始工作，并在接下来的两周里不时出现在该物业中。室外洗衣房和厕所屋顶的修缮工作于11月8日星期二开始。泥瓦匠弗雷德里克·威利斯和他的助手弗雷德里克·琼斯把建筑物的前门开着，因为他们不断进出收集设备。大约上午10点，琼斯正在前台搅拌材料时，一个年轻女子抱着一个婴儿下楼，由另一个年轻女子陪同。她把婴儿放进婴儿车然后离开了。他记不起再见到她了。泥瓦匠们在第二天之前完成了对洗衣房天花板的修缮，并且在接下来的整周里，由于将工具储存在小建筑里，他们经常进出这个小建筑。
When their work finished on Friday, November 11, Jones cleaned and swept the room thoroughly before leaving the property for good. Both men were certain there had been nothing out of the ordinary there during that period. All five workmen were shown a crime scene photograph of the wash house that depicted the timber pile by the sink. Carpenter Robert Anderson identified the planks as floorboards he had removed from the ground floor hallway on November 14. He left them in the wash house for the tenants to use as firewood. These statements were at odds with Timothy Evans' final confession. He had described placing the bodies of Beryl and Geraldine in the wash house on November 8 and November 10 respectively. Yet, the workmen had been accessing the small room on both those dates.
当他们的工作在11月11日星期五结束时，琼斯彻底清理并打扫了房间，然后彻底离开了该物业。两人都确信在那段期间那里没有任何异常情况。所有五名工人都被展示了一张洗衣房的犯罪现场照片，照片显示了水槽旁的木材堆。木匠罗伯特··安德森确认这些木板是他在11月14日从底楼走廊拆下的地板。他把它们留在洗衣房里供租户作柴火用。这些陈述与蒂姆·埃文斯的最后供词相矛盾。他曾描述分别于11月8日和11月10日将贝里尔和杰拉尔丁的尸体放置在洗衣房中。然而，工人们在这两个日期都曾进入过那个小房间。
Upon realizing this discrepancy, Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings summoned plasterer Frederick Willis and his assistant Frederick Jones to clarify matters, along with their manager Raymond Phillips. Detective Jennings asked Phillips to speak with him first while his two employees waited in another room. Three hours passed and Willis and Jones grew frustrated. Finally, Jones was brought in for questioning. Detective Jennings wasted no time in telling him that his earlier statement was incorrect, as the bodies had been placed in the wash house before he concluded his work there on November 11. Jones was certain this could not be the case, as he had not seen anything suspicious in the wash house the entire time he was at 10 Rillington Place. He was insistent, refusing to budge from his story. His boss, Raymond Phillips, was called into the room and told,
在意识到这一矛盾后，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯传唤了泥瓦匠弗雷德里克·威利斯和他的助手弗雷德里克·琼斯以澄清事情，还有他们的经理雷蒙德·菲利普斯。詹宁斯侦探首先要求菲利普斯与他谈话，而他的两名员工则在另一个房间等待。三个小时过去了，威利斯和琼斯变得沮丧起来。最后，琼斯被带进来接受讯问。詹宁斯侦探毫不迟疑地告诉他，他先前的陈述是不正确的，因为尸体在他于11月11日结束那里的工作之前就已经被放置在洗衣房里了。琼斯确信这不是真的，因为他在里灵顿广场10号的整个期间都没有在洗衣房里看到任何可疑的东西。他态度坚决，拒绝改变自己的说法。他的老板雷蒙德·菲利普斯被叫进房间并被告知：
We've got 30 or 40 witnesses to prove the bodies were in the wash house, but your man says they weren't. Phillips turned to Jones, pointing out that if the police said this was the case, then it must be so. Jones altered his statement, writing that he now recalled clearing out the wash house on Tuesday, November 8, not Friday, November 11. Frederick Willis was then asked to join them. He too began to doubt his own recollections and changed his statement, adding the words, I feel now that it would have been quite possible for anything to have been under the sink in the corner. An officer was dispatched to 10 Rillington Place to verify the amended details with the Christie's, who had become the primary witnesses in the case. John Christie confirmed that on Tuesday, November 8, the plasterers told him they had finished the repairs on the wash house and lavatory.
“我们有30或40名证人证明尸体在洗衣房里，但你的人说没有。”菲利普斯转向琼斯，指出如果警方这么说，那就一定是这样。琼斯修改了他的供词，写道他现在回想起是在11月8日星期二清理了洗衣房，而不是11月11日星期五。随后要求弗雷德里克·威利斯加入他们。他也开始怀疑自己的记忆并修改了供词，补充道：“我现在觉得角落水槽下面完全有可能放着任何东西。”一名警官被派往里灵顿广场10号，向已成为案件主要证人的克里斯蒂夫妇核实修改后的细节。约翰·克里斯蒂确认，在11月8日星期二，泥瓦匠告诉他他们已经完成了对洗衣房和厕所的维修。
He also clarified that they had stored their tools and materials in the front room of his flat from that date until November 11. Thomasina visited Brixton Prison to see her son. She had tried to visit him while he was under arrest, but was told she would have to wait until he'd been formally charged. Upon reuniting with him after weeks of no contact, Thomasina asked, Tim, why did you do it? He responded, I didn't do it mum, Christie done it. Before explaining that he hadn't even realized that Geraldine was dead until police brought him back to London.
他还澄清说，从那天起直到11月11日，他们一直将工具和材料储存在他公寓的前厅里。托马西娜拜访了布里克斯顿监狱看望她的儿子。她曾试图在他被捕期间探望他，但被告知必须等到他被正式起诉。在失联数周后与他重聚，托马西娜问：“蒂姆，你为什么要这么做？”他回答说：“妈妈，我没有做，是克里斯蒂干的。”接着他解释说，直到警察把他带回伦敦之前，他甚至没有意识到杰拉尔丁已经死了。
Timothy claimed that police had interrogated him until five o'clock in the morning to coax a confession from him. He pleaded with his mother to have John Christie visit him, stating, He's the only one who can help me now. Timothy Evans was granted legal aid for his defense as he had no money to pay for an attorney. He continued to profess his innocence, though his legal team viewed his sworn statements as very damning. Their brief noted that it would be difficult to decide whether to try for an insanity defense or provide an alternative scenario in line with their client's claims. Timothy's barrister Malcolm Morris visited him in prison on a number of occasions. During these meetings, Timothy explained that he had been scared police would become violent with him if he didn't confess to the murders.
蒂姆声称警察对她进行了审讯，直到凌晨五点才诱使他招供。他恳求母亲让约翰·克里斯蒂来探望他，并说：“现在只有他能帮我了。”蒂姆·埃文斯获得了法律援助来为自己辩护，因为他没有钱支付律师费用。他继续宣称自己无罪，尽管他的法律团队认为他的宣誓供词非常不利。他们的简报指出，很难决定是争取精神失常辩护还是提供符合其客户主张的替代方案。蒂姆的大律师马尔科姆·莫里斯曾在监狱里多次探望他。在这些会议期间，蒂姆解释说，他曾害怕如果自己不承认谋杀，警察会对自己使用暴力。
He reverted back to his second statement, blaming John Christie for killing Beryl, despite there being no evidence of her having undergone a botched abortion. He remarked that John must have killed Geraldine as well. Morris warned his client that the court probably wouldn't believe this version of events, and if he was to insist on it as his defense, then he would be required to testify. Timothy understood and readily agreed to do so. British legal practice at the time meant that even if a defendant was charged with multiple murders, they would only be prosecuted for one. Therefore, the prosecution had to decide whether to try Timothy Evans for the murder of Beryl or Geraldine.
他回到了第二份供词，指责约翰·克里斯蒂杀害了贝里尔，尽管没有证据表明她曾接受过失败的流产手术。他 remarked 约翰肯定也杀害了杰拉尔丁。莫里斯警告他的客户，法庭可能不会相信这个版本的事件，如果他坚持以此作为辩护，那么他将被要求出庭作证。蒂姆理解并欣然同意这样做。当时的英国法律惯例意味着，即使被告被控多起谋杀罪，也只会因其中一项被起诉。因此，控方必须决定是审判蒂姆·埃文斯谋杀贝里尔还是杰拉尔丁。
In cases where two murders were tied together in a single event, evidence that related to the first murder could be given in a trial about the second, but not the other way around. After some consideration, they chose to proceed with trialling the accused for Geraldine's murder. This way, they could still enter evidence about Beryl's death into court, thus strengthening their case against him for the murder of Geraldine. The trial commenced on Wednesday, January 11, 1950, at the Central Criminal Court of England and Wales, commonly known as the Old Bailey. There was little media interest in the case, and it was barely covered by the daily papers. Before proceedings began at 1030, Timothy Evans' legal team were startled to learn that key witness for the prosecution, John Christie, had a criminal record. This was despite Chief Detective Inspector George Jennings stating that John's record was, quote, as white as the driven snow.
在两起谋杀案在单一事件中联系在一起的情况下，与第一起谋杀案相关的证据可以在第二起谋杀案的审判中提供，反之则不然。经过一番考虑，他们选择继续审判被告谋杀杰拉尔丁。通过这种方式，他们仍然可以将关于贝里尔死因的证据引入法庭，从而加强他们针对他谋杀杰拉尔丁的指控。审判于1950年1月11日星期三在英格兰和威尔士中央刑事法院（通常被称为老贝利）开庭。媒体对该案的兴趣不大，日报也几乎没有报道。在10点30分庭审开始前，蒂姆·埃文斯的法律团队震惊地得知，控方关键证人约翰·克里斯蒂有犯罪记录。尽管侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯曾声称约翰的记录是“洁白如雪”的。
Three decades earlier in 1921, John Christie stole two money orders during his employment as a postman, leading to a three-month prison sentence. Three years later, he committed larceny twice and was again sent to prison. The same year, he and Ethel separated, and John struck up a new relationship with a woman he met in London named Maude. Five years later, he was convicted of assaulting Maude after striking her in the head with a cricket bat. He was sentenced to six months' hard labour. His final conviction was for stealing a car in 1933, for which he served another three months. The prosecution and police were satisfied that John Christie had since become an upstanding citizen, worthy of testifying on their behalf in a murder trial. Following the outbreak of World War II, he worked as a war reserve constable until his resignation in 1943.
三十年前的1921年，约翰·克里斯蒂在担任邮递员期间偷了两张汇票，导致了三个月的监禁。三年后，他两次犯下盗窃罪，再次被送进监狱。同年，他和埃塞尔分居，约翰与他在伦敦遇到的一名叫莫德的女子开始了新的恋情。五年后，他在用板球棍击打莫德头部后被判袭胸罪名成立。他被判处六个月的劳役。他最后一次定罪是在1933年偷车，为此他又服刑三个月。控方和警方对约翰·克里斯蒂此后已成为一名正直的公民、有资格在谋杀审判中代表他们作证感到满意。二战爆发后，他一直担任战时预备警察，直到1943年辞职。
He and wife Ethel had since reunited and had lived at 10 Grillington Place since 1938. Despite this, the defence regarded John Christie as an unreliable witness. When John was called to give evidence at trial, he gave detailed accounts of arguments he'd overheard between the evidences, painting their relationship as destructive. He claimed that on the evening of November 10, the night that the prosecution was alleging the accused had killed baby Geraldine, Timothy had arrived home, quote, extremely angry, upset, really wild. He told John that he had quit his job and was hoping to find a new one in Bristol, where Beryl and Geraldine supposedly were, and would be selling his furniture before leaving. Defence barrister Malcolm Morris cross-examined John, using the opportunity to share his defendants' explanation for both murders by stating, Well, Mr Christie, I've got to suggest to you, and I do not want there to be any misapprehension about it, that you are responsible for the death of Mrs Evans and the little girl.
他和妻子埃塞尔此后重聚，自1938年以来一直住在里灵顿广场10号。尽管如此，辩方仍将约翰·克里斯蒂视为不可靠的证人。当约翰被传唤在审判中作证时，他详细描述了他在埃文斯夫妇之间无意中听到的争吵，将他们的关系描绘成具有破坏性的。他声称在11月10日傍晚，即控方声称被告杀害婴儿杰拉尔丁的那天晚上，蒂姆回到家时“极其愤怒、心烦意乱、非常疯狂”。他告诉约翰他已经辞去了工作，并希望在布里斯托尔找到一份新工作，贝里尔和杰拉尔丁据称就在那里，并打算在离开前卖掉家具。辩护大律师马尔科姆·莫里斯对约翰进行了盘问，借此机会分享了被告对两起谋杀案的解释，并宣称：“好吧，克里斯蒂先生，我不得不向你暗示，我不想对此产生任何误解，那就是你要对埃文斯太太和小女孩的死负责。”
While he acknowledged that he had known about Beryl's unwanted pregnancy, John firmly denied suggesting that he could perform an abortion for her. When asked whether he owned any medical textbooks, John said he owned a St John's ambulance manual that included diagrams of the human body, but had never shown it to Timothy Evans. He called the accusation that he helped carry Beryl's body downstairs ridiculous, as he had been bedridden with severe back pain and information of the small intestine during the week in question. In a final attempt to undermine John's credibility, Morris concluded his cross-examination by addressing his prior convictions. Other witnesses for the prosecution included Ethel Christie, whose testimony matched that of her husband's, Timothy's aunt, Violet Lynch, and Dr Robert Tear, the pathologist who had performed the autopsies of Beryl and Geraldine. He described how the pair were killed by strangulation and made it clear that there was no evidence of damage to Beryl's uterus indicative of an abortion procedure. All four of Timothy Evans' confessions were read to the court. The defense aimed to discredit them and managed to find one unreliable aspect. According to an inspector who was present at the time Timothy provided his statements, chief detective inspector George Jennings mentioned where Beryl and Geraldine's bodies were found before Timothy provided that information himself.
虽然他承认知道贝里尔的不想要怀孕，但约翰坚决否认曾暗示自己可以为她实施流产。当被问及他是否拥有任何医学教科书时，约翰说他拥有一本圣约翰救护手册，其中包含人体图解，但从未向蒂姆·埃文斯展示过。他称指控他帮助把贝里尔的尸体搬到楼下的说法是荒谬的，因为他在有关的那一周一直因严重的背痛和小肠发炎而卧床不起。在最后一次试图削弱约翰的可信度时，莫里斯通过谈及他先前的定罪结束了他的盘问。控方的其他证人包括埃塞尔·克里斯蒂（其证词与丈夫的相符）、蒂姆的姑姑维奥莱特·林奇，以及对贝里尔和杰拉尔丁进行尸检的病理学家罗伯特·蒂尔医生。他描述了两人是如何被勒死致死的，并明确表示没有证据表明贝里尔的子宫受到损伤以指示流产手术。蒂姆·埃文斯的四份供词全都被宣读给法庭。辩方的目标是抹黑它们，并成功找到了一个不可靠的方面。据一位在蒂姆提供供词时在场的督察所说，侦探总督察乔治·詹宁斯在蒂姆自己提供该信息之前，就提到了贝里尔和杰拉尔丁的尸体被发现的地方。
The defense only had one witness, Timothy Evans. Timothy explained to the court that he had initially blamed a stranger he met in a cafe for Beryl's death in order to protect John Christie. Upon learning that her body wasn't in the storm drain as he believed it would be, he had decided to tell the truth. He described his latter two confessions as a load of lies that he'd made up because he was destroyed at learning of Geraldine's death and believed police would knock him about if he didn't comply. He stated that when police showed him his wife and daughter's clothing and the other artifacts found with their bodies, they also revealed that the pair had been in the wash house concealed by timber. In his final question to his client, Malcolm Morris asked, Had you anything left to live for when Geraldine was dead? Timothy replied, No sir. Prosecutor Christmas Humphries referred to the defendants' known and extensive history of lying. He described to John Christie, a World War I veteran who also worked in the War Reserve police during World War II as a perfectly innocent man who had no motive to murder his neighbors.
辩方只有一位证人，那就是蒂姆·埃文斯。蒂姆向法庭解释说，他最初为了保护约翰·克里斯蒂，将贝里尔的死归咎于他在咖啡馆遇到的一名陌生人。在得知她的尸体不在他以为会有的风暴渠中后，他决定说出实话。他将后两份供词描述为一堆谎言，因为他在得知杰拉尔丁死讯时深受打击，并相信如果自己不顺从，警察会殴打他，所以才编造了这些谎言。他表示，当警察向他展示他妻子和女儿的衣服以及与她们尸体一起发现的其他物品时，他们还透露了这对母女一直被藏在洗衣房的木材下面。在对客户的最后一个问题中，马尔科姆·莫里斯问道：“当杰拉尔丁死后，你还有什么活下去的理由吗？”蒂姆回答说：“没有了，长官。”检察官克리스마스·汉弗莱斯提到了被告已知且广泛的撒谎历史。他将约翰·克里斯蒂（一名一战老兵，二战期间也曾在战时预备警察部队工作）描述为一个完全无辜的人，没有谋杀邻居的动机。
Humphries asked the defendant, Can you suggest why he should have strangled your wife? Can you suggest why he should have strangled your daughter? To both of these questions, Timothy replied, No. At the conclusion of his 10 minute long closing argument, Humphries asked the jury. Even if Christie had been responsible for the woman's death, why should he two days later go up to that flat and strangle an innocent little baby lying there aged 14 months? Even this fluent liar, who will lie as and when he pleases, cannot invent an answer to that question. The defense's closing argument was significantly longer. Malcolm Morris reminded the jury that unlike John Christie, Timothy Evans had no previous convictions for violent behavior.
汉弗莱斯问被告：“你能暗示他为什么要勒死你妻子吗？你能暗示他为什么要勒死你女儿吗？”对这两个问题，蒂姆都回答：“没有。”在长达10分钟的结案陈词结束时，汉弗莱斯问陪审团：即使克里斯蒂要对女人的死负责，他为什么要在两天后上楼去勒死一个躺在那里14个月大的无辜小婴儿呢？连这个惯于说谎、随时随地都能撒谎的流利骗子，也无法对这个问题编造出答案。辩方的结案陈词要长得多。马尔科姆·莫里斯提醒陪审团，与约翰·克里斯蒂不同，蒂姆·埃文斯没有暴力行为的前科。
He asserted that elements of his client's story were not something that an uneducated illiterate man could invent. He explained that his client made no admissions that Geraldine was dead until after he was told her body had been found, at which point he confessed due to his fear of the police. The trial judge reminded the jury that they were only required to reach a verdict regarding Geraldine Evans' murder. Despite the defense's story that Beryl had died after arranging for John Christie to perform an abortion, the judge clarified that she had not died from such a procedure and added, Evans is a person who does not hesitate to lie. The jury deliberated for 40 minutes before returning with their verdict. They found Timothy Evans guilty of the murder of his one-year-old daughter Geraldine. In 1950, death was the mandatory sentence for murder. When asked if he had anything to say as to why the court should not sentence him to death, Timothy replied,
他断言，他客户故事中的某些元素不是一个未受过教育的文盲能够编造出来的。他解释说，直到被告知杰拉尔丁的尸体被找到后，他的客户才承认杰拉尔丁已死，在那个时候，由于对警察的恐惧，他才供认了。审判法官提醒陪审团，他们只需要就杰拉尔丁·埃文斯的谋杀案达成裁决。尽管辩方称贝里尔在安排约翰·克里斯蒂进行流产后死亡，但法官澄清说她并非死于此类手术，并补充道：“埃文斯是一个毫不犹豫撒谎的人。”陪审团经过40分钟的审议，带着裁决回来了。他们裁定蒂姆·埃文斯谋杀他一岁的女儿杰拉尔丁罪名成立。1950年，死刑是谋杀罪的强制性判决。当被问及他是否有话要说，说明法院不应判处他死刑时，蒂姆回答：
No, sir. He remained silent as the judge stated. Timothy John Evans, the jury has found you guilty of willful murder and the sentence of the court upon you is that you be taken from this place to a lawful prison and thence to a place of execution and there you shall suffer death by hanging. May the Lord have mercy on your soul. At these words, John Christie broke into sobs from his seat at the back of the courtroom. As the Christie stood to leave, Timothy's mother shouted at John, Murderer, Murderer. Ethel replied, Don't you dare call my husband a murderer. He's a good man. Timothy Evans was taken to Pentonville Prison in North London to await his execution.
“没有了，长官。”当法官宣判时，他保持沉默：“蒂姆·约翰·埃文斯，陪审团已裁定你蓄意谋杀罪名成立，法院对你的判决是，将你从这个地方带到合法的监狱，然后再带到行刑地点，在那里你将遭受绞刑处死。愿主怜悯你的灵魂。”听到这些话，约翰·克里斯蒂在法庭后排的座位上失声痛哭。当克里斯蒂站起来要离开时，蒂姆的母亲向约翰大喊：“杀人犯！杀人犯！”埃塞尔回应道：“你休想叫我丈夫杀人犯。他是个好人。”蒂姆·埃文斯被带到伦敦北部的本顿维尔监狱等待行刑。
He was a model prisoner who was generally liked by the guards. One officer noted that Timothy talked of his deceased wife and child, almost as if he had forgotten the crime. While another commented, he speaks of his wife with respect. Timothy passed time playing cards with other prisoners or discussing football and boxing. He found renewed faith in the Catholicism he had been raised with and attended mass every week while also receiving regular visits from a priest. His mother, stepfather and sisters visited often. Timothy continued to maintain his innocence. A month after his trial, he appealed his conviction on several grounds, including that evidence relating to Beryl's death should have been inadmissible and that the judge had misdirected the jury to find him guilty.
他是一个模范囚犯，普遍受到狱警的喜爱。一名警官指出，蒂姆谈论他死去的妻子和孩子时，几乎就像他已经忘记了罪行一样。而另一位则评论道：“他带着敬意谈论他的妻子。”蒂姆通过与其他囚犯打牌或讨论足球和拳击来打发时间。他在从小到大信仰的天主教中找到了新生的信仰，每周都参加弥撒，并定期接受神父的探视。他的母亲、继父和姐姐们经常来探望。蒂姆继续坚称自己无罪。审判一个月后，他以多个理由对定罪提出上诉，包括与贝里尔死因相关的证据本应不可采纳，以及法官误导陪审团裁定他有罪。
His appeal was ultimately dismissed. Once again, Timothy showed no visible distress at the verdict, but upon returning to prison, he began pacing in his cell. His execution was scheduled for Thursday, March 9, 1950. Five days beforehand, Timothy appeared before a medical board to confirm he was of sound mind. He again attempted to recant his confessions, stating, I didn't care what happened to them, so I made the statement. He speculated that John Christie had killed Geraldine to get her out of the way. He didn't dwell on his situation, but found it painful to discuss.
他的上诉最终被驳回。蒂姆再次对裁决表现出没有任何可见的痛苦，但在返回监狱后，他在牢房里开始踱步。他的行刑日期定于1950年3月9日星期四。五天前，蒂姆出现在一个医疗委员会面前，以确认他精神健全。他再次试图翻供，声称：“我不在乎他们发生了什么，所以我做了那份陈述。”他推测约翰·克里斯蒂杀死杰拉尔丁是为了把她弄走。他没有纠缠于自己的处境，但觉得讨论这件事很痛苦。
The board found no cause to provide a medical reprieve. Two days before his execution, Timothy was visited by his mother and sisters. He asked them if there was any hope, and his mother replied, We have done all we can, son. There's nothing more. I want you to make your peace with God. Don't worry, you'll go to heaven. At their final visit, Timothy's older sister, Eileen, stayed behind after the others had left and said, Look, Tim, you've got nothing to lose now. Tell me the truth so that I can know. Did you do it? He answered, No, Eileen, I didn't do it. Christie done it. On Thursday, March 9, 1950, Timothy spoke with a priest before the executioner arrived at 9 a.m.
委员会没有找到给予医疗缓刑的理由。行刑前两天，蒂姆的母亲和姐姐们来看望了他。他问她们是否还有希望，他的母亲回答：“我们已经尽力了，孩子。没有别的了。我希望你与上帝讲和。别担心，你会上天堂的。”在他们最后一次探望时，蒂姆的大姐姐艾琳在其他人离开后留了下来，并说道：“听着，蒂姆，你现在没有什么可失去的了。告诉我真相，好让我知道。是你干的吗？”他回答说：“不是，艾琳，我不是我干的。是克里斯蒂干的。”1950年3月9日星期四，蒂姆在上午9点行刑官到达之前与一位神父交谈。
He was taken to the prison's execution shed, where a hood was placed over his head, and he was hanged. His body was buried in an unmarked grave in the grounds of Pentonville Prison. The execution failed to make headlines. Five months later, the owner of 10 Rillington Place sold the house to a 35-year-old Jamaican immigrant. By this stage, Charles Kitchener had permanently vacated the property, and the building's new landlord planned to lease each of the rooms in the middle and upper floor flats to maximize returns. Seven new tenants moved in, four of whom were also from Jamaica. John and Ethel Christie remained in their ground floor residence, though they were displeased by their new neighbors. The pair held racist views and made a number of complaints about noise and intrusions to their property to a free legal advice service. Eventually, John Christie negotiated exclusive access to the property's backyard on the grounds that he and his wife needed privacy.
他被带到监狱的行刑棚，头上被套上头套，随后被绞死。他的尸体被埋在本顿维尔监狱内的一个无名墓穴中。这次行刑并未引起轰动。五个月后，里灵顿广场10号的房主将房子卖给了一位35岁的牙买加移民。此时，查尔斯·基奇纳已永久搬离该房产，这栋建筑的新房东计划将中层和顶层公寓的每个房间都租出去，以实现收益最大化。七名新房客搬了进来，其中四人也来自牙买加。约翰和埃瑟尔·克里斯蒂仍住在他们的一楼住宅里，尽管他们对新邻居很不满。这对夫妇持有种族主义观点，并向一家免费法律咨询服务机构就噪音和对其房产的侵扰提出了多次投诉。最终，约翰·克里斯蒂以他和妻子需要隐私为由，争取到了对该房产后院的独家使用权。
By Tuesday, March 24, 1953, the Christie's were no longer living at 10 Rillington Place. That afternoon, Beresford Brown, the tenant who now occupied the top floor flat, was making some repairs to the Christie's old kitchen after the landlord had given him permission to make use of it. As he installed some brackets for a wireless radio, he tapped a portion of the room's rear wall and discovered that it was hollow. Beresford peeled back a small portion of wallpaper, revealing a small, hidden alcove tucked away alongside the kitchen. He shone a torch inside and was alarmed at what he saw. Tobay continued. Next week. Copyright© OSHO International Foundation There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到1953年3月24日星期二，克里斯蒂夫妇已不再住在里灵顿广场10号。那天下午，现在住在顶层公寓的房客贝雷斯福德·布朗在房东允许他使用克里斯蒂夫妇的旧厨房后，正在对那里进行一些修缮。当他为无线电收音机安装一些托架时，他敲击了房间后墙的一部分，发现它是空的。贝雷斯福德剥落了一小块壁纸，露出了厨房旁边一个隐藏的小壁龛。他用手电筒往里面照了照，被他所看到的情景吓了一跳。待续。下周见。版权所有© OSHO国际基金会 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。